a breakthrough after more than three
months of talks Sudan's government's
signing a peace deal with the Sudan
People's Liberation Movement north or SP
lmn led by Malecha gur it's part of a
bid by the Sudanese transitional
administration to end years of conflict
in various parts of the country the deal
that we have signed addressed a number
of issues it addressed the issue of
legislation in the two areas South
Kordofan and the Blue Nile
it also addressed the issue of land and
wealth and power distribution as well as
security arrangements we will lead our
country forward the SP lmn started
fighting the Sudanese government in 2011
after accusing it of marginalization and
impeding democracy a remnant of the vehm
southern sudan SPLM it's made up of
Sudanese who supported the movement and
stayed behind following South Sudan's
independence in 2011 mostly in South
Kordofan and Blue Nile states the two
states were supposed to have the chance
to decide whether they wanted to be part
of Sudan or join South Sudan the SPLM
and itself is split into two with the
other led by Abdul Aziz in helú who's
yet to start negotiating with the
government the war has killed tens of
thousands and displaced nearly 400,000
more than 20 rounds of talks between the
SPLA men and the former Sudanese
government overthrown in April last year
failed to produce results by signing
this deal it confirms our determination
to reach a peace deal that will change
the lives of people and establish an era
free of marginalization and violence
under the previous regime people in
Sudan generally and areas of conflict in
particular have paid the price
as a result of injustice and lack of
political stability now is the time to
end the misery and bring the prosperity
the people of Sudan deserve the peace
talks were mediated by neighbouring
South Sudan which is ultimately ating
between Sudan's government and other
groups such as rebel movements from the
western region of Darfur
[Music]
the groups that are still holding out
should be convinced to do you those who
have signed today so that all of you
come to an agreement with some group
still in talks and others yet to even
start negotiating Sudan's road to peace
remains long but Friday's signing offers
a glimmer of hope for those who've
suffered from years of war
Hiba morgan al jazeera